شهدت مواجهه كرواتيا واستراليا ضمن
منافسات المجموعه السادسه في مونديال
المانيا عام 2006 اشاره الحكم الانجليزي
جراهام بول ثلاثه بطاقات صفراء في وجه
اللاعب نفسه قبل ان يطرد فكيف حدث ذلك
حصل المدافع الكرواتي جوزيف سيمونيتش على
انذاره الاول في الدقيقه الحاديه والستين
فيما اشرت في وجهه البطاقه الصفراء
الثانيه في الدقيقه 90 رغم انه كان يجب ان
يغادر لقاء مطروضا مباشره بعد البطاقه
الثانيه الا ان حضور اللاعب الكرواتي
استمر في ظل غفله من حكم اللقاء ومساعده
ويبدو ان بقائه في الملعب بصوره غير
قانونيه لم يكن كافيا يغير من سلوكه في
الدقيقه 93 بلغ اللاعب في الاحتجاج على
قرار اتخذه الحكم يحصل على البطاقه
الصفراء الثالثه لكن في هذه المره كانت
الثالثه ثابته اتبعها الحكم اخيرا ببطاقه
حمراء